it's not just draymond it's a lot of
guys you know that
you know trying to discredit what i do
every night or who i am as a player or
like it's it's it's part of it you know
and for me uh i would always take that
as respect if i wasn't
if i was a average defensive player or
average player they wouldn't talk about
me right
[Music]
hello there
what's up how you doing
great
as you're walking in i hear my producers
say what are you wearing are you wearing
your own shirt but that's not you that's
not me yeah
that's my guy yeah no i love that that's
it that's a great great tribute um
so you're at the bleacher report offices
for the first time first time yes and
you know i have to begin with your your
relationship with bleacher report
i think that you know we all saw uh in
your press conference you talked about
the way that the media covers you and
you specifically talked about bleach
report and what we decided to post and
not to post so i want to give you the
platform to elaborate
on how you feel about how vr covers rudy
gobert i mean i appreciate that yeah uh
i still follow them by the way i still
forget you guys uh i like i appreciate
the content yeah
but yeah it's true that i mean i've
we've talked about this many many times
you know over the years uh
you know i
with when you look back and when you see
the bigger picture like uh it took me
years to understand how like it was more
about
you know and not just a [ __ ] report
it's you know it's supposed center it's
a lot of platform that are looking more
for for views for interactions for
content you know then for the actual
uh informative part of it so it's uh
you know i understand it
i mean i'm not the most flashy guy out
there i'm not the most exciting guy to
watch but yeah as long as the narrative
is
the right narrative is being pushed is
what matters to me yeah well i mean i
think this is an important perspective
to get you know what the player thinks
about the way they're covered the clips
that are chosen the good versus the bad
and those things
what do you think you attribute it to
though
like why people choose the clips that
they choose
i think these are
i mean all the algorithms and and you
know obviously the the players that
the markets and the players that have
been pushed is
the ones that will generate the most
views right it's the way it works and
for every not just beach report i'm not
targeting
oh i am not offended
but yeah
yeah work here yeah i mean
uh yeah it's uh
once again it's something that i think
there has to be a balance between
obviously generating the views and the
content that
uh will get the people excited and get
get the most engagement but at the same
time you know uh
not just manipulate the narratives too
much yeah i want certain type of players
and that's when you know there's been a
few times in the past when i was like
you know i can see through the lines and
see what what is being done right here
especially because you know i think that
if you you have a game and you're like
oh my god this was a great block or
great dunk and you're anticipating you
know going back to your phone and
everybody talking about this block or
dunk because someone posted it but then
you see wait this moment wasn't posted
i mean that's okay for me yeah because i
you know i don't i don't search that
necessarily you know i think
obviously there's a younger generation
of guys that i really grew up in this
social media and like really and i've
seen that in it's funny you know like
guys really search for those
highlight plays and stuff like that i i
don't search for that you know i don't i
don't ask for posts or anything i don't
think it's that's not why i play the
game i play the game because i enjoy it
because i like to win
and uh i like to inspire people
but um
yeah when it's like
you know you do you do a 100 positive
things and and you you there's one
slipper edge you get dunked on or you
get crossed over and
and then that's been highlighted and
that's what the people you know the
mainstream people see and
and then they create their own narrative
around you right and that's what they
see so they're like what
these guys win dpoi but all i see is him
getting crossed so what what is he doing
right on the court yeah
and that's why it's it can be tricky but
you know over the years i've
i've learned how to see the bigger
picture and
i used to like when i was younger
obviously be more
uh you know you can get a little bit
upset but now it's like i'm in a
different place you know with with
more wisdom
and you're in your old age you've just
gotten wiser
yeah oh me too it's close it's coming
i'm i'm excited for 30 though yeah me
too i honestly am well you know now that
you're at the bleacher offices you can
just like hack into the system and make
sure you're the you're the number one
girl
okay so let's get straight to it um are
you winning defensive player of the year
this year
that's a good question i mean time will
tell but um
you know it's been uh it's been a really
good year uh
for
for us as a team you know we had some
some ups and downs but
i really like the way our team has been
uh
you know has responded to the adversity
and then
and every year you know uh
every time i step on the court i try to
be the best you know the best defensive
player in the world and then
and my team needs me to to be that in
order for us to
be who we want to be so
uh i hope so you know i hope so i hope
you know as usual that the number and
the impact will speak for itself and uh
and we'll see we've got a few more games
to play yeah i think i saw the little
you know like the power rankings came
out yesterday and right now i think
giannis is
one what do you think separates you from
a guy like giannis
um i mean i have a lot of respect for
janice you know
you know i'm
i'm inspired by you know the way it's
been
came into this league and you know and
similar to me but differently like we
both like drafted i was drafted 27 he
was drafted 15 or 14.
and uh yeah he was about to
you know uh it's inspiring what he's
done win a championship but also the
player that has become so
you know i would never i never compare
myself to other guys i think everyone is
you know i respect every single guy in
this league i think
we all have different journeys different
you know different struggles different
like it's
you're never gonna hear me criticize
other guys
but um yeah he's having a great year and
i do think at the end of the day uh when
you look at defensive throughout the
year
uh for me it's really the impact
you know it's uh
there's a lot of guys that you know the
the fans tend to go for the flashy plays
sometimes and and it does play a role in
the narratives out there but i think the
impact is really
uh what separates you know guys and uh
and um you look at the teams you know
guys the teams without their guys and
when the guys is there you see the
difference
i think that's really a
pretty good uh way of judging somebody's
impact
well the defensive player of the year
conversation
is so interesting with you because it's
very layered
i have known you for a very long time we
have had lots of conversations about
this award and
you know why people get voted what it
means to be a defensive player of the
year
there seems to be this
major backlash that comes whenever you
are defensive player of the year
i know you disagree with a lot of that
backlash why do you think it happens
so i do think
i think the backlash comes usually from
from
the same people the same crowd
i think
uh like when i talk to retired players
when i talk to people coaches gm's
people that really understand this game
and watch me night in the night out
uh
there's never any negative comments
being made they all
uh respect and appreciate you know the
way i play the game and what i do for my
team every night
so it's really the i think there's a gap
between the
the overall perception
and between the real impact and and what
i do as a player the way i impact the
game and i think that's when
you know when you talk about social
media and all that stuff that's when it
comes into play right there's usually uh
yeah there's a gap between the
perception and reality pretty much
what do you think the perception is
and what do you think the reality is
i think there's been uh
i mean when
you know when you look on social media
and from what i've been hearing over the
past few years there's some narratives
for example that
i can't get out on the perimeter stuff
like that and
it's usually that that clip of me uh
spinning around guarding steph that
makes me laugh too actually but 2017
right yeah and usually it's the only
argument that people have uh to try to
prove that
i can't get on a perimeter when it's
like
look at the data look at the numbers
look at like who is who last year was
the number one big at guarding the
perimeter in terms of efficiency guys
don't score and
once in a while you get you get crossed
like david booker like crossed me over
and he'll step back last year and it was
everywhere on social media and it was a
great play but it's uh
for me it's most it's mostly about what
you don't see on social media that's the
reality yeah like the one highlight that
you don't see
can affect your perception but it's not
the reality pretty much
so how would you tell us how would you
evaluate you know how you guard the
perimeter how would you evaluate your
performance there really well i think uh
i'm really comfortable and once again
i've i think
uh i've had to adapt my game
every year you know
like
i used to be
like four or five years ago i was much
more comfortable regarding the perimeter
and
obviously i was really dominant inside
and
and doing what i've been doing you know
over the years but
the game has evolved
there was more and more shooting big uh
emerging guys like your kids cat
you know a lot of shooting big brook
lopez and i had to
i had to train myself to to become
comfortable regarding in all this kind
of situations and
you know and queen schneiderlin played a
big part in that in in really
challenging me in order for me to to
keep growing and
and
you know i've done it every year and
once again
what i say is backed up by all the
numbers you can look at the data i mean
it's out there and there's so many
so many ways to measure efficiency and
the way i i can impact uh whoever i'm
guarding
and yeah after after year after year you
know you can see that the game evolves
but i'm
it's kind of fun for me too because i
have to
you know challenge myself every year and
and
you know i think i'm at a point today
when i'm really comfortable regarding
guys anywhere and uh
and my team needs me to be able to to do
that in order for us to be where i want
to be so
once again the numbers back it up and
and i'm just you know
keep trying to grow every year yeah i
mean i think this is an important
conversation for you because
any time there's a narrative about
anyone they should have the outlet and
the chance to respond to things
and so i know patrick beverly he went on
old man in the three and he talked about
you and when he was talking about you he
said
how are you the best defensive player if
you don't even guard the other team's
best offensive player
so i want to give you a chance to answer
that question
how is that true
and you know me you know i'm not a like
i don't i never campaign for myself i
think you know i think the game like
i think when you when you play the right
way your game always speaks for itself
and then once again we have a lot of
ways of measuring
uh
someone's impact you know on the court
nowadays which is which is i think is
great
um
i mean i
what people don't got to understand
about what i do on core is like i i'm
not just guarding one player
like when i when i'm out there i'm my
mind my mindset is to guard the whole
team like i'm i'm controlling like
there's five guys on the court and
like i don't go out there thinking oh my
god my whoever i'm guarding i'm wanting
to score zero points but then if
everybody else scores
and we lose it's like did i really
impact my team in a positive way
so i'm going out there thinking i gotta
guard this whole team and like limit
like make sure that this team is not
scrolling 140 points tonight and make
sure i'm leading helping my teammates
because at the end of the day you don't
do
like it's a team sport you don't do
anything on your own so my goal is
really to
go out there and and communicate with my
teammates and make sure that
i have the most impact that i can on my
team and
and ultimately on the other team making
sure that
you know
my guy my score 30. i don't want that i
have pride obviously
but
if if my guy scores 30 but the other
team's called 80 points that's a that's
best defense in the league that's
amazing
i'll take that yeah so you're saying
you're you're operating within the
system that is like presented to you
i'm affecting the whole team i'm not
worried about one player i'm turning out
the whole team yeah well something i
thought was really interesting you know
when you all played the mavericks
you know late in the game you were
switched on to luca
how would you evaluate your performance
regarding luca
i mean we
you know once again i'm comfortable
regarding anyone and luka is an amazing
player so
you know it's very smart you got you got
you got that step back you got you can
drive he's really crafty drawing files
and he's a really good passer so
you know there's some guys that you you
know you can you can double team and
they can
it's hard for them to read but luca it's
like if you want to be successful it's
hard to double team because it's it's
big you can pass
you can see the floor so you have to
you have to make him earn it and you
know that's my that's my challenge every
time you know just try to
make him earn it make him hit the
toughest shot possible and
and
and he's going to do it at times and if
he does you know
you clap your hands but make him work
and that's that's my mindset every night
i might be wrong but watching that game
it felt like you had kind of a different
sense of pride in that performance you
know that you were on the guy you were
guarding the perimeter you were you did
a good job in locking him down
in different situations did that moment
feel different for you
and also how much of that switch was
coach and how much of it was you
uh
so what you know every night it happens
every night yeah like i end up switching
uh
like our defense is not primarily
switching
but
we know that usually it's gonna it's
gonna happen throughout the game uh
whether it's early or late uh there's
usually a situation especially with
shooting bigs or shooters when
when teams play with like five strollers
to to space me out
like we would rather have me on the ball
at the end of the day we write a switch
and
have me guard the ball and then uh
you know make them earn it and
you know it happens every night so
obviously i think because it was luca
doncic and he's such a really good
player like he brought people's
attention a little more but
um you know yesterday i was already i
was ended up switching on reggie jackson
every night we're going to be switched
on on a good player and
usually
you're not going to see the highlights
but usually it's it's uh
for if you look at the data once again
it's it's
it's to our advantage
i know you don't like to compare but
if you win a fourth defensive player of
the year award do you feel like that
does legitimately put you in the
conversation for like one of the best
defenders of all time
i mean i
every day i step on the court uh i want
to be
the best defensive player of all time
that's that's that's the mindset that i
have i don't like to compare like you
say i don't like to compare the
different errors i think the game
is evolving so much um you know every
every five every 10 years
the game is changing so
you know i do i do think that
uh
you know the day i retire
you know we we're gonna look at it and
that would be a good time to to to judge
but
until now you know i wish people would
just
appreciate and just enjoy the not just
me but just
you know all the guys that are out there
you know accomplishing some some things
for this game
and uh
you know i think it's a conversation
that we'll have when i retire yeah okay
that's fair
i mean although you're smiling and i
feel like you're kind of like yeah i
know what i think about myself as a
defender
and you're just
i mean i know what i think you know what
i think i just told you but uh i do
think you know i think
you know whatever you do in this league
there's always gonna people are always
gonna challenge you you know there was
the narrative a few years ago he was
rudely kind of got in a perimeter now
it's like really cannot
uh impact in the playoffs which has been
proven not to be true by the numbers
once again i had one bad game
and uh it's been the narrative
now so now it's always you know it's i
kind of enjoy it because it's like
people are challenging me to
um you know to keep raising my level
every year and and i do want to win a
championship so i think
you know uh for me the next step now is
really to to help my team uh try to
accomplish that and
we'll see what
what's going to be the next challenge
now social media is something that you
and i have both talked about often both
on my side and on your side it's just a
conversation that we have had
can you genuinely say that
whatever people say about you whether
it's your character or your game
whatever they say on social media that
it doesn't bother you
so i've learned from a very young age
you know obviously i've got drafted and
this there was always there's always
been criticizing you know and i think we
all deal with that you know whether your
influencer your artist
nba player i think everyone
uh if you're going to be on social media
you're going to be you're going to see
some negative stuff right like there's
no i don't know one person in the world
that never had a negative comment on
social media so
just i've just always kind of embraced
it
uh
you know try to
sometimes you
uh i think lebron said that one time
like sometimes you're just looking for
the one guy that's gonna say some
negative before game two get that
motivation and that's kind of the
mindset that i've had over the years but
at the same time i realized also that it
could affect you you know because it
does you know the way the subconscious
works right you think you could but then
it's in the back of your head and it's
like that guy said that i got
like he did say that and is it true and
you think about it so it's
and you're second guessing yourself sort
of even when you can't yeah you can't
you can i realize that i can really uh
mess with you in a way but
i think for me there's more positive
uh seeing it uh sometimes and negative
so yeah
even though i
have a different relationship with
social media that i had
over the past few years i still
you know pay your attention to what's
going on yeah well because you know
whenever i'm doing an interview and just
the research portion of the interview
one thing i always do is tweet search
the person's name always
and it just feels like
any dislike it's like so magnified for
you
would you agree with that
magnified for like
for me like the way i see it yeah it's
like there are tweets that are just
people like i don't like rudy gobert and
i'm like well like why
you know it feels like there was a lot
of that
online and i would assume like you see
that too and i'm just curious like
mentally how that would make you feel
so obviously
like it's it's never it's never great
you see that but
i'm able to
uh once again see the bigger picture and
and the reality is that these people
don't know me
like they don't know who i am
they've seen a video of me uh maybe
touching mics or video of me uh
i don't know blocking their favorite
player or i don't know whatever it is
like it's
these people don't know me they don't
know
my character they don't know all the
things i do for the world like they
don't
they don't really know who i am so it's
like can i really be mad for them not
knowing me
like no you know i wish they would know
me i wish they would educate himself
like try to dig a little deeper about
who i am but
most people don't so
you know it's part of it it's part of it
and i think once again when we talk
about
uh you know the big social media
platforms that can highlight you know it
can really impact the narratives out
there like
it's like i've never seen
any of this platform talk about the good
things that i do or you know the like
the positive right so it's it's part of
it it's part of it and but i i don't let
it affect me anymore because i know
these people don't don't know me yeah
okay you said i don't let it affect me
anymore at what point did you stop like
was there a specific moment you were
like this is getting to me and i can no
longer allow it to have this this power
over me
i think
the only time that you really was was i
would say was tough was the curvy
situation because people were already
questioning who i am as a person my
character and my intentions so that was
the toughest part then
people are questioning like my game or
what i do on the court like you know
it's basketball so i don't want
like you want to be great you want to be
the best player out there and you want
people to be proud of you and people to
respect you for what you do on the court
but
it's part of it you know we we know that
but yeah questioning your character and
who you are as a human being what was
the little
most frustrating part of it
but i think it really helped me grow too
as a person and like
be
like
more detached with social media and
people's opinion yeah because i mean you
know i think you are a very kind person
i think you're a very good person
and when that moment happened i remember
talking to you and i know how much it
affected you that
people were
making that about who you were this like
one moment was being blown up into like
this is who rudy gobert is
how does it feel that for so many people
it's almost like
you are synonymous with covet
people think like you're patient zero
yeah yeah
i mean
like people are like he is the reason
it's like well
people were mad at me because they
thought i took away their sports like
they are home sitting on couch and they
cannot watch their game because it's
really good
mics it's like yeah
i mean it's like someone was going to
get coped like that was going to yeah i
mean anyway i don't want to get back to
this bit yeah
yeah they looked in the water and used
water and people had covered in november
or december yeah and i had it in march
no i mean i i think it's silly like i'm
not i think but yeah like it's but it's
just totally a thing i mean like even it
is but and i do think you know i mean
that made me realize how people are
already controlled by
the narratives and and
the media and all that and
once again it was it was a really
big learning experience for me you know
and and i think he made me grow and
and you know i took a few bullets for
people out there but at the end of the
day i could
i could take it so yeah it wasn't easy
but i took it and it made me grow
and my things with social media it's
like
any person like
the smart people are the only people i'm
concerned about online and like there's
no smart person that truly believes
that to be true you know what i mean
like so who cares really you're like oh
actually no no no there's no smart mommy
i don't want to say i don't want to yeah
you know call people out
and stuff but
um yeah just learning experience you
know you see
i mean for me it really helped me grow
as a person and
and i do believe everything happens for
a reason so i think
you know i was being put in this
position for a reason and uh you know
and i was about to do a lot of good uh
after that so
you know it was uh
it was i think it was a tough situation
not just for me for the whole world and
and if people react like this it's
because they they have fear right they
have fear they have anger and
usually they have to put it on somewhere
they have to put on someone so
i took a lot of that and
you know i was aware of it but it's uh
i'm happy that
you know i was able to grow from it yeah
and
i'm actually i'm kind of grateful for it
because you know it was
it was it was a great uh it was a tough
process but made me stronger yeah no
i'll never forget i remember like you
said to me once you're like there are so
few people in the world that could
handle like half the things that like
i'm having to handle you know but it's
always those people that have opinions
and like have things to say so i mean i
think social media is
sometimes the best of people and
sometimes the absolute
worst of people so i totally understand
that um but i do want to give you a
chance like tell anyone who doesn't know
you
like about rudy gobert
all the parts they don't see there's so
many parts that people don't know about
me but i don't know well get specific
yeah okay so you're like this question
is not pointed enough when you say you
know they aren't talking about the good
you know what do you mean by that
i don't know i do a lot of great work
maturity for example uh through these
kids right yeah which is foundation so
we building a school in africa right now
we
i mean we've been doing a lot of uh cool
like block shot event when like we go to
for example we go to a city we go to
sacramento and
we choose a local kid charity and for
each block that i get we will donate uh
a thousand dollars to that charity we
also invite kids to the game and i can
meet them after the game and stuff so
just a lot of cool stuff you know that
i'm i'm
you know i think about how i can impact
uh the younger generation how i can
impact
the world in a positive way and and i
always thought that kids was
you know the future so
you know for me
kids be able to to dream and you know be
able to accomplish what they want to
accomplish is always been something that
i really care about
no i love that i vouch good for you but
i believe that to be true uh i want to
talk about the jazz for a little bit
no obviously
in season you guys are always amazing
regular season there's all these
expectations for you guys you're playing
great
and you know the narrative is you get to
playoffs yeah and just something happens
why do you think
that has been the case in the past and
why is this year maybe different
i think i think
i think it's not just the jazz i think a
lot of teams have had that you know uh
like being good in the regular season
and and then
uh you get to the playoffs and it's a
different type of uh
different type of basketball is
different type of atmosphere
and for us last year you know being
being the best team in the league during
the regular season
uh almost like having no injuries i
probably missed two games last year one
or two games
and then get into the playoffs and then
and starting facing adversity right we
mike only gets hurt
we don't have a point guard like we
we we up two against the clippers and
then you know we also know it's a tie
game we lose game five and and then
anything can happen right and
you know i think it comes with
experience
most of the time and then
we had a lot of uh
in a way disappointing post season over
the last few years all different you
know we were in the bubble we're up 3-1
against denver yeah
and then uh
uh you know we there's a pro this uh
there was that protest and and
we canceled some get a cancer we don't
know if we're going to keep playing or
not and then we all of a sudden it
starts again and the momentum is
different and we lose
not to have any excuse but like every
year has been different and we face
different challenges and for us now i
think we're in a place where we
understand that
being first in the league doesn't
guarantee any championship doesn't
guarantee anything
and we understand that it's about being
good at the right moment yeah and and
for us this year has been our mindset
you know building good habits
but one spray of time hopefully be
healthy and and
be the best jazz basketball team that we
can be
but i mean how important is that this
year to like actually get
over that hump because you can't forever
be you know the team that almost did it
or the team that you thought was good
enough but wasn't you know i mean we
don't want to be an almost team for sure
i think we
you know we
over the last nine years i've been in
jazz for nine years and my my first year
we won 25 games
i was in the g league and
and i always told myself like i i i want
to win a championship for this
organization and
you know we
we've built you know queen snyder got
him a second year
and we my fourth year we made the
playoff for the first time
we beat the clippers uh
game seven and then we lose to the
warriors with katie and everybody
and then we you know every year we felt
like we you know we got better and
better and better and then
now is definitely the time when i'm like
you know like it's a championship or
nothing and
you know i think all the struggles and
the adversity that we've been through as
a group as an organization
uh you know it's preparing us for
hopefully this this moment this year
when
or next year or whenever but we we
definitely feel like we
uh we have something you know we have a
cool opportunity and something to
accomplish
what team in the west gives you the most
problems
i think our biggest enemy is ourselves
no but like what team that's not that
you touch us
what team that is not the jazz gives you
to be honest this
like when you look when you look at from
one to eight even one to ten like
i mean this year has been obviously
phoenix is he's been having an amazing
year here we go there's an answer
phoenix has been you know having a great
year and even last year they did uh but
uh
yeah it's
we feel like anybody anybody can beat
anybody pretty much and it's that's why
i say we our biggest enemy because i
think like if we
sorry if we're healthy and if we come in
the right mindset uh
i i think we can beat anyone
in a seven game series
but you can also lose to anyone so it's
it's on us to you know get ready keep
finish the season the right way and then
uh come in and
try to accomplish what we're trying to
accomplish
is there something for you that like
feels different
about this year and you all i think of
course seeing how you're playing okay i
think compose is different you know and
there's one thing that
you know early in the season could be
seen as negative but i think uh right
now i'm really grateful and happy that
we've been through this adversity you
know these stretches when i was injured
donna was donovan was injured
you know we had
i think at some point we had six or
seven guys that had coveted and
and we lost you know a lot of games in a
row and then
you know uh last year was different
because we didn't have that during the
season
and we had kind of a little bit of that
during the playoffs and we weren't ready
for it so now it's like
we've had adversity we we've learned
from it and we're ready to
you know pretty much go through anything
yeah absolutely and i think so much of
it too is just
getting over that hump just gives you a
different level of respect
right so much of it is like you said
like not wanting to be that that almost
team i think some people even look at
the performance that you had
specifically in the playoffs last year
when you look back
on that
what first comes to your mind about the
playoffs yeah the playoffs last year
like when you all played the clippers
like what sticks out to you about that
performance
i think we
you know i think
uh
like what we've learned in milwaukee was
was a pretty cool example of that last
year like they were down to oh
they were down 2-1
a few different series and
you know and people are kind of like
were calling them out and
but they have the belief in themselves
like they knew that
uh you know it wasn't uh it wasn't a
sprint it was a marathon and
they were able to to step it up step up
you know game after game to raise their
level and
and you know it was a it was a really
cool and inspiring you know i think a
story to to see them win a championship
because there wasn't first in the in the
east you know they
in a way even if i don't like
comparisons like it was similar to us
this year when they had
a lot of adversity during the regular
season but
you know they they just raise their
level during the playoffs it's it's the
mindset that we want to have we want to
have the mental toughness to
be able to
because there's no there's no
championship with our adversity
you know there's no championship like
you don't sweep everybody and win a
championship the warriors kind of did
that one year
but they had
they had a pretty special team yeah but
this year we don't feel like anyone's
going to sweep everybody and and win a
chairmanship so it's how we're going to
react to that adversity and
and
the mental toughness that we're going to
we're going to have that's going to make
the difference
you know one thing that's great about
you and i think that it it shines
through in the way that you also answer
your questions and you've said it about
yourself is you always take the high
road that is something that you you have
kind of dedicated yourself to doing um
and you actually had that quote when
someone talked to you about draymond and
the remarks that he made about you
this whole situation i think is very
fascinating to me this whole rudy gobert
draymond green thing so i want for you
why do you feel like that relationship
is where it is right now or i guess lack
of relationship
yeah i mean when you say relationship is
what he's saying about me because i'm
not talking about him you're right so
i mean when i see him in person he's
always very nice and respectful you know
so it's uh
you know as long as that that stay the
same you know
like things that have been said about me
on podcasts or it's not just german it's
a lot of guys you know that
you know trying to discredit what i do
every night or who i am as a player or
like it's it's it's part of it you know
and for me uh i will always take that as
respect if i if i wasn't
if i was a average defensive player or
average player they wouldn't talk about
me right so
i would always take that as respect and
uh
you know and then you know
guys have platforms now and they have a
voice and and
when their voice can can affect uh
the
average narrative and can affect you
know people's mind and people uh
opinions
like it's their right to use it
you know is are they right are they
wrong
once again there's data there's numbers
there's you know a lot of people that
know this game that watch the game and
that are kind of neutral you know that
don't have anything to gain and they can
make their own opinion
so for me it's like
i'm never going to talk down on anyone
you know i respect all these guys know
that
once again like i respect every guy in
the league i think everyone first of all
being in this league is already
something so it's a great accomplishment
and
it's hard to
also be in this league and and sustain
this league and be consistent you know
and they will tell you the same
so i show respect you know and
if you disrespect me in person it's a
different story but you can say whatever
you want i mean yeah well this whole
thing i just think is
very interesting because you look at it
it's like what happened specifically
between these two
that you know he feels the way that he
does
and you know me so i just asked i was
like you know i'm i'm going to be
interviewing rudy and i'm trying to
understand why this exists between you
guys i want every i want kumbaya you
know
but he actually said something that i
had no idea about i don't know if he'd
ever talked about
he said that
he had issues with actually the french
national team
and i guess how he felt like you guys
were talking to them on the court and
that was one of the reasons that he felt
this way
towards you
do you know
do you give you any details
i mean do you want to hear the exact
text you're just like
i mean i want details because okay he
said he didn't come for me
let's see
if you're gonna hate me because some
other guy says some stuff i don't think
he hates you i don't care
he said
they as the french national team have
been very mouthy when it comes to us yet
they don't beat us when it matters
playing with team usa it's us against
the world and to hear guys like him and
evan fournier get in the media and talk
[ __ ] as if they don't already know how
[ __ ] really goes pisses me off
well show me show me what [ __ ] i talked
so you disagree like you're like i
wasn't doing that i don't talk [ __ ] so
like i want to see the evidence of me
talking [ __ ] but i
i love the compellingness yeah i think
you know i think
i think in a way it's cool that
team usa is finally like
getting mad at the team because they
used to kick everybody's ass for for the
past few years and for the past 30 years
or since basketball started
so
you know i think it's in a way it's i
think it's good for basketball that you
know they are getting mad at us
because they feel like they have a
little more a little bit more of a ch
even though they're still a better team
i think they have much more talent that
we have
it's great that we have a little more
competitiveness and
in terms of the [ __ ] talking
i don't talk [ __ ] so
it didn't come from me okay
how personally did you take
that match-up
i mean it's a dream you know for me it
was always a dream to
uh try to represent my country and then
try to win the gold medal so
whether it's team usa or
all the great spain slovenia all these
great basketball teams uh
you know it's
it's uh
like you in front of me so i'm trying to
win a gold medal and
and uh yeah there's competitiveness you
know like if it wouldn't be fun if it
was easy and for us the challenge has
been over the last few years it's been
team usa has been our biggest uh
biggest challenge so it's always you
know it's and it's guys that we face you
know throughout the whole year and
and it's cool to be in a position when
you're the underdog too because we
always the underdog so it's
yeah it's just uh competitiveness you
know it's and it's a dream for me to to
um to not just first of all beating
these guys was a dream like it was we
had never beat team usa before
and we did it in uh in the world cup in
china
uh in 2018
and now being able to
yeah do that is uh you know it's just
comparingness and dream
so is there any world where you feel
like this is squash i think you're great
i think draymond's great and i just
think there should be a there's no beef
on my side i mean as long as you keep
your respect uh
you know you stay in line and don't
disrespect my family and stuff like that
you know it's just competitiveness
uh and it just
you know i've
once again every time every time i talk
about drama or not
anybody else i'll show respect so
if these guys want to disrespect me it's
their choice you know and and i'll take
that as respect because because i know
that's
you know it's competitiveness and then
you know and
i'm a quiet person but some guys are
different there are different
personalities and
you know they're gonna they're gonna
express their mind and it's fine okay
that's fair and it's weird like some
people are like into it they're like
yeah
who do you dream on people love beefs
you know yes again like
i'm gonna go back to this again but like
beef generate more uh interactions it
generates more like even me like when
when you watch a video when there's a
fight or something you
like you you want to watch right yeah
it's more
interesting so so i get it but
yeah i'm not
i'm i'm chilling okay that's fair so
like this uh i guess it's not it's not
the beef's not gonna end with this
episode unfortunately even though i know
it's not on on your side or yeah like
that uh yeah i don't have a beef with
anyone yeah yeah and i even said him i
was like i mean do you see a world this
is fine he said he's not my teammate it
doesn't have to be fine and i i mean i
guess that's true too
i'm not i don't care yeah yeah you're
like i'm i'm over it it does matter to
me okay that's fair i have like a super
super random
thing to talk about
because i was talking to some of your
your teammates about this moment when
you all were on the plane
and the birds flew into the engine
and
everybody else just got this report of
like okay they had to make an emergency
landing
but what i'm hearing is like you guys
actually thought like it was over like
y'all were very scared on that plane is
that accurate
yeah it was it was really scary yeah um
i'm just thinking about it like it
something that you know i flew so many
planes in my life and
i'm always
not scared but it's always like when it
moves you're like is it my last my last
time you know you ask yourself right
and you like try to make yourself feel
better and stuff yeah but uh yeah that
time like that feeling of you know
something exploding and like the plane
was like making a weird noise and
and you could feel that it was really
struggling to fly
and also when you look at the flight
attendants and you see that they are
scared like i've never seen a scared
flight attendant before so it was like
if she's scared i mean something's wrong
yeah and um
yeah i mean guys were everyone has a
different way of expressing
you know
yeah no because i heard like some people
were crying like they thought it was
done yeah some people were praying some
people are crying yeah um
i was pretty calm
externally
yeah but
yeah just
yeah you were questioning like i didn't
want to text my mom because i felt like
like she could she could like
really like get really scared and i did
i want to make sure that you know she
wasn't panicking yeah like overreacting
so
you know just had to yeah be patient for
a few minutes and
it was tough but
you know once we found out that it was
just only one engine
that was blown up
then we
we felt a little better but
i still to this day like i still uh have
some little ptsd for me yeah like it's
it's it's still hard like i still
apprehended a bit flying
how much of you thought like no this
plane is going to go down
i don't know for i know a lot of guys
talked about that and a lot of guys
actually saw the flame coming out of the
engine and stuff so
it's probably even worse
for myself
i was just trying to convince myself
that it wasn't my time
you know and
that's it it's the only thing you can do
it's you and your mind you know at the
end of the day and
i was happy to yeah to
the
next few days was you appreciate it a
little more everything yeah and then
you know it's it's i guess it's part of
it but it was really
it didn't happen for for last 20 years
so it was pretty
yeah pretty uh
unlucky
and lucky at the same time yeah but i
mean it's wild to think about a moment
that even if it's like a little in your
head you're like oh my god is this like
is this it like what are you actually
like what's wrong you understand that
you know you can make that much money
you can be successful you can like
life is so fragile yeah it's like
it gives you perspective even though you
know i
i try to always work on you know my mind
and my perspective of life and
everything but
you realize that everything is so you
know
like one little moment and
it can be done like i was
just like when i was watching that kanye
documentary and it's the same like you
just realize that you know one like it's
it's
it's very fragile yeah no i mean i'm
like someone has to do like
an oral history on that day because i
think it would be really interesting
like getting the perspective of each of
you all and what you were thinking in
that moment and what you saw i would
love to yeah yeah i mean uh this kind of
thing that we've talked about it a
little bit but it's like i don't want to
you you almost don't want to bring back
those memories to a lot of guys so you
don't want to talk about it
but yeah i mean it was really
yeah it was
it was really scary yeah like it was
more serious than portrayed like i
thought y'all just had to land like i
didn't think it was that bad yeah it was
it was bad i never had that in my life
like it was
like if
we felt something an explosion like we
got hit by a rocket or something
and and then the plane was
wasn't right you could feel that it
wasn't right yeah and it was in the
silence because the pilots were trying
to figure it out and the silence for
like was five or ten minutes when we
didn't know what was going on
so we didn't know
and the pilot we're like we we try to
work it out we try to work it out and
flight attendant and a panicking so it's
it was tough new stuff but
you know i'm glad that
we made it out and yeah
and um yeah it's once again something
that you
like it gives you more perspective too
yeah well no i'm i'm glad you are okay
and you made it through
rip to the birds though
yeah so yeah
because they they didn't see the the
light of day
you know for sure and and
the pilot was actually about to dodge
most of them
because if you because
there was a big flock of birds and
it was about to slide on that way
and so they only hit the left engine and
one bird hit the it's not funny but one
bird hit the front the front of the the
plane like there was blood on the on the
front sheet and stuff oh like when you
got off you saw that if you would have
blown
both engines that would have been uh
much more yeah
much more serious probably because
you can the the plane planes are built
to be able to flow to to glide
but with one with without engines it's
really harder for for the pilots to
to move around so we probably would have
landed on the salt lake yeah
oh my goodness
i mean it was it was yeah just a pretty
uh
unfortunate experience you've had just
like quite an eventful past
two years
yep yeah how do you feel like you're
different coming out of it
different i think everything
everything in life is is an experience
without like we all we we see things are
good or bad but i think every
every experience that we that we
everything that we experience is is a
lesson in a way and you just learn and
life is about going forward you know
until
until it's your day you keep going
forward you keep learning and
you keep trying to
you know fulfill what you want to
fulfill
when you when people think of rudy
gobert as a player what do you want
to stick out to them
i think
just a guy that a competitor you know a
guy that always did anything he could to
to to win
uh
that's many as a player i i hope i want
to be remembered for more than being a
basketball player and i want my legacy
to be much more than that but if you
talk about just me the player
yeah someone that you know always did
uh just a winner a winner someone that
did anything cool to uh
you know be a good leader and then
and help his team winning
who are your like four favorite guys to
guard in the league favorite guys to go
um
i mean i don't have a favorite guy but
obviously i love challenges and okay so
i'm gonna give you an option you either
have to tell me four favorites
or tell me the two toughest
the two toughest
i mean the thing is like
there's so much talent in this league
right now i think it's never meant as
much talent overall like
on every night there's a guy that that
can go off or every night there's a guy
that you know gives you like
uh can give you match-up problems right
because the talented level is
is through the roof now and
you know i think i mean these
generational talents like staff like
jokic uh luca so whoever
so in my position uh definitely uh
your kitchen embiid
i mean the two
um two guys that are very unique
and
you know it's always i know that i need
to be ready for those matchups because
they just put a lot of pressure on on
your team and you have to
you know there's no perfect game plan
right you have to always uh
uh
adjust you have to adjust you have to
uh try to surprise them you have to
yeah bring it to them you know
differently that uh some some other guys
and
it's uh that's what makes it exciting
right
something you said actually i thought
was interesting
you said that
europeans tend to play with like more
emotions
um on the court and i think you were
talking about this after that mavs game
what did you mean by that
i think the way we
i don't know what it is
i think the way maybe we
something with the formation in europe
and then something the way we've been
taught the game
um
i know i feel that and you can see it
right europeans usually have more
um
can be
have more emotional reaction on the
chord or get a little more mad
give me an example react
and it could be an example of myself
yeah i mean like uh
and i've got better at it but like i
play with emotions like i play with you
know like i'm like if something like if
i get fouled and it's not cold or like
something like that or
like you show a little emotion i think
it's
yeah maybe just the way we
i don't know i don't know how to explain
it probably the way we've been
taught since very young and
um it's different type of you know the i
think americans are more
taught how to be like really good
individually
and we're more tired of you know how to
play as a team and maybe the result is i
don't know what it is but
it's intriguing do you think that has
helped you more or hurt you more
i mean i'm
if you look at my career and
probably helped probably help me to be
to be that type of player i don't know
what kind of player would have been if i
would have played in college or in high
school and college and everything but
you know i am really grateful for the
path that i had and uh
and
you know i'm i'm grateful for for my
journey
and you had said
after that same game you're like you
want the refs to be able to do more
about what players are saying to each
other am i saying that out of context
you were talking about i was talking
about
i mean when guys say some stuff
uh but they know there's like uh
you know
it's you on the court and they're on the
bench on call and like i think
you know as a man
like you want to be able to
you got to navigate like like guys
calling you names and stuff and
at the same time you don't want to hurt
your team because if you react
like you get attacked or you get ejected
or whatever and
so yeah just just uh
just be able to keep the game more in
check
certain times and i love to play
physical i love
i prefer like i love you know when not a
lot of things are being called but
there's different between physicality
and
uh disrespect in a way so it's like
like this
the game i think you have to keep keep
that in check yeah because you're like
there are some things that were said
that i would never say
i don't i don't
and once again that's me but i don't
like the most i would say is maybe like
when i block a shot i would say give me
that [ __ ] or stuff like that yeah
yeah but i i don't disrespect guys or
you know like target guys verbally you
know that's the way i am once again like
everyone's different okay that's bad i
think we have fan questions
yeah a couple
okay um
in terms of defensive player of the year
take yourself out of the equation
if you cannot win defensive player of
the year who wins
that's a good question
um
[Music]
i have to dig into because i haven't
really paid attention to the numbers and
stuff so i i would probably have to do
my research you haven't paid and i don't
want to i don't know other defenders you
know
i pay attention to like what's been said
a little bit and stuff like that but i
don't i didn't dig right into the data
and the numbers and
i think it's it would be unfair to them
to judge them without doing that
so i don't know but some guys have had
pretty good uh
very good well one thing you talked
about you know in terms of you know
judging someone's defensive ability you
talked about just peer impact so if we
know the disclaimer that you don't have
the numbers in front of you but you know
about impact
who's a guy you're like they impact
their team defensively on a different
level there's a lot of guys this year
that i mean not a lot but like there's a
handful of guys this year that i thought
have been really good um you know like
uh the young kid from memphis jackson
robert williams with celtics uh i really
like
my current bridges yeah
um
i don't the thing the problem when i do
that is that i'm gonna forget some guys
like bam he's a really good defender
well someone's gonna say oh well you
didn't say
um i mean yanis is obviously a really
good defender
uh
draymond is a very good defender
he's he's missed a lot of games but he's
a really really good defender
uh i have a lot of respect for all those
guys so yeah i love to to to see how
guys take pride in you know
trying to win that world and then being
a
and just
be like put the mind into being a great
defender i think it's great for the game
but so even when you put yourself back
in the equation do you feel like the
defensive player of the year race right
now is like
there's a guy
way ahead of everyone or do you think
it's kind of a log jam right now do you
think the winner is clear because i
don't know if i believe that right now
i think uh obviously the season is not
over yeah
once again we have to look at the number
the impact
and it's not my
i'm not the one to to you know to say
who should we or should not i want to
win obviously i think
uh i do think uh if you look at the
impact uh
i do think once again like it's uh it's
clear but
you know uh
it's it's a long season and
and uh
you know i respect all those guys and i
think it's
we're gonna see how it goes
once at the end yeah i'm a voter so i'm
always like what do i think
but it's like i get major anxiety makeup
order because you want to make sure you
make the right choices and i do think
it's very important that
you take a lot of time to make those
choices the fact that some people's
money hinges on the voting is wild
so you just always want to make sure you
have like an educated answer so i
understand for sure and then i love that
you really take the time to do that you
know and take the time to
doesn't mean that
there's a perfect answer for everything
but at least you take the time to
research and and
and make your own opinion and and listen
to what people say and to i think you
have a good feel for the game so
if everyone does that you know we win a
good place
another one
funniest player
you've ever played with
funniest player you've ever played with
um
i play with a lot of funny guys
i'm joining us i was just gonna say he's
funny yeah it's a bit annoying but
[Laughter]
um
what else was funny
i play with a lot of clowns
remember rich richard jefferson used to
be funny mm-hmm rookie yeah yeah he's
still funny yeah he used to make me
laugh a lot but he was a great pet
though yeah he really uh
he took care of me so i appreciate that
okay joe ingles richard jefferson
another one
okay last one
um
you've been on one team for your entire
career in a small market what do you
think about some of the biggest names
switching teams when things don't go
as planned
i think i think it's hard for me to
to judge other guys for the decisions
that they make right it's uh
i know that my personality is is
uh is that i wanna
i'm stubborn so i wanna keep you know
keep trying keep trying keep trying with
the same with the same team and then
obviously
like if if it doesn't go it doesn't go
but uh that's my mindset
this has been my mindset for my whole
life
uh but yeah i think guys
guys should be allowed to
um
yeah if they're not happy like why would
they why would they play somewhere if
they're not happy right
so you know i'm who am i to judge
uh
what guys decide to do or not i think
it's a
you know it's a great game but it's also
business and
you know you have to respect
you know guys decisions
and then
and yeah i do think though i do think
like it can impact a legacy though like
i have a lot of respect for someone like
there for example that
i think the championship like has a lot
of value because of the way
you know he kept he kept going with the
same team and he kept trying but
you know uh at the end of the day it's a
game and
you know you got to respect guys
decisions and
guys uh happiness
that's fair you know i hope
that you feel like
in some ways you are able to
address narratives that are out there
about you whether it's about your
personality whether about whether it's
about your play as a defender um i think
that's important i don't know how often
you have been able to
i don't think it's about addressing it i
think it's more about
having obviously like the opportunity or
like for people to get to know me a
little more i think it's uh if they take
the time to listen and not just pay
attention to the
flashy quotes
take the time to listen the whole thing
and
you know like it's what it's about right
we don't
be quick to judge people without knowing
them and i think
if people would take a little more time
to
you know just have more empathy and
and get to know uh read through the
lines i think you know it would be
social media will be more peaceful for
sure
oh social media and peaceful i don't
know if those two things go together
hopefully one day one day
thank you so much for your time thank
you
you